salut aujourd'hui une nouvelle vidéo qui
pop un petit peu à l'improviste c'est
faux parce que c'est le lundi soir les
vidéos
tu aurais dû me reprendre tu étais pas
attentif donc la base c'est le lundi on
est lundi mais nous on a on a revu tout
le planning pour vous sortir cette vidéo
là car si vous avez suivi sur la chaîne
secondaire au mois de mai et aussi sur
mon Instagram j'ai en 2022 créer mon
premier programme télévisé incroyable
c'est pas une blague ça s'appelle la
grande expérience ça va être diffusé
après demain donc le 21 sur TMC à 21h25
je vais vous dire ce qu'il y a dedans
mais surtout dans cette vidéo je vais
vous faire voir ce qu'il n'y a pas de
temps c'est le pizza c'est bizarre c'est
bizarre ou pas c'est bizarre tu peux
être plus sympathique quand je fais des
interactions s'il te plaît c'est
terrible on a tourné ce programme au
mois de mai parce que tu aimes si vous
voulez absolument le diffuser avant fin
juin et du coup avant enfin je viens
vous l'avez vu il a pas été diffusé
parce que TMC du coup voulait absolument
le diffuser en septembre puis tu as vu
en septembre ça a pas été diffusé et en
définitif on vient d'apprendre que ce
serait diffusé après demain le 21
décembre à 21h25 sur
donc je me suis dit autant vous faire
une vidéo pour vous prévenir mais pas
que aussi parce que quand tu fais un
programme pour la télévision tout ce que
tu enregistré ne veut pas être gardé
parce que il y a une durée à ne pas
dépasser parce que la chaîne aussi elle
fait des choix avec toi etc et donc nous
on a deux grandes expériences de la
grande expérience qu'on a pas pu garder
j'ai récupéré les ruches et vous allez
voir ça
[Musique]
quand j'ai écrit ce programme en 2021
j'imaginais que l'émission elle allait
s'ouvrir sur moi en extérieur en train
de prendre quelqu'un au hasard dans la
rue et faire un truc de mentalisme un
peu fou avant de lancer le concept le
concept c'est pas que je fasse
mentalisme le concept c'est que j'emmène
des personnes à faire des trucs de
dingue avec leur cerveau sur des grosses
expériences ok mais je me suis un petit
truc de mentalisme au départ donc l'idée
c'était d'aller sur les quais c'est ce
qu'on a fait de prendre une personne au
hasard sur les quais c'est ce qu'on a
fait et de faire un truc de mentalisme
un peu dingue c'est ce qu'on a fait
pourquoi on n'a pas à garder tout ça
parce que quand tu regardes la vidéo
finale ça sent le fake à plein nez alors
que c'est pas fake mais ça pue le fake
voici ce qui se passe nous on arrive
avec une équipe de tournage du son des
caméras etc et il faut commencer par
vérifier qu'on aura le droit à l'image
de ce qu'on va faire parce qu'on pourra
pas le faire deux fois vous allez voir
pourquoi donc moi je repère une jeune
femme je demande si elle est d'accord
pour faire ce truc je présente le
programme etc il me dit ok du coup elle
retourne s'asseoir et moi je vais
l'aborder de nouveau puisque maintenant
les la caméra film et on sait qu'elle
est d'accord bonjour
[Musique]
je vous embête un petit peu est-ce que
ça vous dérangerait de faire une
expérience de mentalisme avec moi c'est
rapide c'est filmé mais ça va être très
rapide oui c'est vrai bah alors
levez-vous je vous en prie je m'appelle
Fabien chanter oh c'était pas bien et
votre prénom c'est Apolline ok on va
faire quelque chose d'assez simple et ça
va se passer que dans votre tête vous
avez vu ça fait pas naturel parce que
c'est pas naturel parce qu'on lui a
demandé à penser aux autorisation et à
partir de là je trouve que la suite elle
n'était pas crédible en fait et qu'on
pouvait pas le garder à cause de ça
alors que pourtant c'est une bonne
expérience de mentalisme elle est réelle
et elle était assez incroyable parce
qu'après moi je lui demandais de penser
à n'importe quel groupe de musique enfin
regardez je vous demandais juste d'abord
pour vous calibrer de penser à une
couleur n'importe laquelle vous y pensez
maintenant vous avez une couleur en tête
est-ce que c'est du rouge oui ok ça veut
dire que ça se passe bien entre nous et
Dieu sait comment vous fonctionnait
c'est parfait est-ce que vous pouvez
penser à une chanson s'il vous plaît
alors ça peut être n'importe quelle
chanson mais il faut que quand même que
ce soit un tube oui alors vous vous la
redonnez s'il vous plaît allez-y
redonner cette chanson ça peut être le
refrain ça peut être le couplet et c'est
ça qui va falloir que j'essaie de
percevoir ok je vais monter un petit peu
le volume pendant que vous la chanter
que dans votre tête d'accord ça a l'air
d'être quelque chose d'acheter joyeux
parce que je vois aussi les mains qui
bougent l'équipe ça me donne des
intentions sur la chanson elle est pas
trop triste je remonte un peu le volume
d'accord c'est quelque chose que une
dizaine d'années on va dire grosso modo
qui doit être souvent repris je remonte
encore encore un petit peu le volume ok
j'ai quelque chose qui se précise j'ai
vraiment envie de danser deux sujets
j'ai l'impression que ça reste dans la
tête facilement c'est ça c'est ce qu'on
peut appeler un tube vraiment un tube ok
d'accord tout le jeu c'était de lui
induire à avoir une seule réponse
possible sans qu'elle se rende compte
qu'elle avait pas le choix et que ça
venait de moi et pas d'elle pour qu'elle
me propose Ben L'Oncle sol avec la
chanson soulman
[Musique]
parce que j'avais demandé à Ben de venir
il s'installer discrètement derrière
elle pour être prêt à jouer ça donne ça
c'est ce que vous pouvez me redonner la
chanson à laquelle vous pensez
c'est seulement et c'est ben L'Oncle sol
qui a écrit ça vous l'avez déjà
rencontré ben non
[Musique]
regarde Spike Lee
de devant si c'est trop cool en vrai
c'est beaucoup trop cool merci beaucoup
à Ben L'Oncle d'avoir accepté de venir
d'ailleurs mais vous comprenez pourquoi
on pouvait pas le faire deux fois parce
qu'après une fois que tout le monde a
fait entendu je veux seulement je
pouvais pas reprendre quelqu'un d'autre
pour le refaire au même endroit et on
pouvait pas rebouger parce qu'on n'est
pas d'autorisation pour aller ailleurs
indéfinitif on a on a juste ce que vous
avez vu là un des moments préférés moi
de tournage mais que j'ai pas voulu
garder parce que je pense que vraiment
le public il me connaît pas et ce serait
dit non mais c'est bizarre c'est une
complice c'est un truc comme ça et
j'aurais vraiment vraiment eu ça
la deuxième chose qu'on n'a pas gardée
c'est ce qui nous a sûrement demandé le
plus de travail le plus de préparation
et malheureusement le résultat il est
cool dans le principe mais ça rend pas
bien à l'image c'est pas très joli à
regarder donc j'ai pas vraiment pu
mettre dans l'émission seulement on est
allé au parc Saint-Cloud j'avais
mobilisé je crois une trentaine d'entre
vous de d'abonnés qui sont venus au
tournage directement on avait des drones
on avait tout ça pour faire une grosse
expérience de mémoire parce que il y a
trois transversales dans l'émission il y
a quelqu'un que je vais prendre et que
je vais transformer en champion de la
mémoire en une semaine il y a quelqu'un
que je vais prendre et que je vais
transformer en détecteur de mensonges
pendant une semaine aussi d'ailleurs
avec des trucs de dingue genre ce
confronter aux négociateurs du GIGN que
vous avez déjà vu sur sur la chaîne
jouer contre des grands joueurs de poker
français enfin des trucs sympas et il y
a des acrophobes des gens qu'on le
vertige que je vais essayer de libérer
de cette phobie là pour le début sur la
mémoire j'avais emmené Jean-Luc Lemoine
dans le parc Saint-Cloud avec 30 d'entre
vous vous devez avoir des tee-shirts de
couleur avec des numéros dessus et un
objet particulier dont on devait retenir
tout ça ça donne des objets des
combinaisons un peu bizarres comme ça
d'accord tu imagines si on peut grève si
on peut greffe un arrosoir à la place je
sais pas si tu gagnes vraiment concours
pétanque 2018 ah mais bon vous étiez
dans boule magazine
excusez-moi vous êtes abonné
alors une main géante qui fait peur
parce que c'est pas le mec qui a greffé
aussi et l'arrosoir tout à l'heure un
emoji caca et dans la grande loterie des
accessoires vous avez gagné c'est quoi
leur nom
et et
vous avez une banane aussi grande que
vous parce que vous avez une explication
à ce phénomène
hot 9 alors quoi comment on appelle ça
et en fait c'est une patate et en fait
c'est une pintade c'est une dingue
à la dernière seconde il y a des
personnes qui n'ont pas pu venir donc on
a pris des gens de l'équipe sera vous
retrouver Fanny
oh [ __ ] je crois que je crée cette
vidéo juste pour vous mettre cette
séquence là avec le poulet sur la tête
mais après ça a été relativement
classique c'est-à-dire que je faisais
l'encodage de tout j'ai essayé de tout
retenir avec Jean-Luc c'est à dire que
là on a fait un passage en revue des 40
personnes essayez vous avez tout retenu
déjà peut-être un peu plus que vous mais
moi j'imagine par exemple si je vous
demandais l'objet qui avait en 5 je ne
vais pas la moindre idée je vais vous
démontrer maintenant parce que tout ça
c'est du blabla que en plus d'avoir
encodé et stocké je suis capable de
faire la récupération des informations
qui sont dans mon cerveau et à la fin on
a tenté la restitution sans faute alors
là nous sommes avec le numéro 27 qui
porte un magnifique arrosoir de saison
l'arrosoir vous allez donner à la
personne numéro 4 s'il vous plaît et la
Perse a annonçant plus bien sûr on a une
trompette d'accord alors vous allez lui
laisser l'ourson peluche par contre
cette trompette elle lui va pas très
bien cette trompette vous allez la
rendre à la personne en numéro 8 s'il
vous plaît en 28 une famille de singes
ça me paraît correct est-ce qu'ils sont
bien deux oui je crois c'est exactement
c'est toute la famille de cette de cette
grande jeune femme nue aussi ce qui
porte une j'ai l'impression que c'est
une coupe ah ça ça fait plaisir donnez
la personne numéro 15 je le connais par
cœur je l'ai vu dans boule magazine je
vous rappelle donc rendez-lui sans
trophées à quoi une bouée en forme de
signe ou de flamant je sais pas
un flamant plutôt
une bouée géante en forme de flamant
rose d'accord et c'est quoi son numéro à
cette personne 31 euh non ça va pas du
tout ça me plaît pas en 31 vous allez
lui mettre plutôt une pieuvre et puis ce
signe vous allez le rendre à la personne
qui est en
24 allez une coiffe de dinde ça je vais
lui laisser pour longtemps donc laissez
lui ça lui va très très bien
il a gagné bravo c'est pas mal
[Musique]
c'était super sympa et nous toute l'idée
c'était que ça se passe avec le drone un
peu graphiquement un peu tout ça et le
tournage franchement c'est pas à la
hauteur de ce que je voulais en terme de
qualité voilà il y avait pas Loïc il y
avait pas le Lolo il y avait pas le Lolo
donc après quand tu quand tu crées une
émission comme ça et c'est moi qui fait
la production de cette émission autant
vous dire que ça fait pas des années que
je refuse des projets télé pour créer le
mien et garder les trucs qui sont pas
ouf donc c'était pas à la hauteur donc
je l'ai pas gardé mais par contre je me
disais que c'était sympa de vous faire
voir un petit peu les images de tout ça
tout ce que vous avez vu ça ne vous
spoile pas l'émission vous verrez que du
nouveau après demain si vous regardez
cette vidéo lundi demain si vous
regardez cette vidéo mardi aujourd'hui
si vous regardez cette vidéo mercredi
hier c'était hier les gars si vous
regardez cette vidéo je dis en tout cas
c'est mercredi 21 décembre à 21h25 sur
TMC je compte sur vous pour regarder ça
à très bientôt Ciao